ils ont devancé squeeze aujourd'hui on
se retrouve une nouvelle fois sur
chivalry mais sur le médiéval warfare
pas sur l'extension des diasporas your
avec mecha voilà aujourd'hui on va pas
jouer aux pirates parce que je trouve
qu'on a c'est jouer aux pirates comme ça
on va jouer des hommes qui pique
voilà où qui envoie des piques thibault
lui là bas lui là bas vas-y tu me suffit
qu'à attention et on prend en charge au
peak 2 peak bon 7 fromages préparés aux
pros sandwich pompiers brochette détesté
sa mort soit le mois mais moi pas tu
manges tu as jeté que de lothian le
trick les gars nul mais tu peux plus
bouger mais je tente ma vie se régénère
ah oui je tiens à dire un mendiant s'est
dit auprès de lui non elle esquive du
pic attention à toi mais qu à bertoua
c'était une femme étaient ses hobbies
public dtc une brochette au final épique
hai ba calais ce plan il est fou mais je
le déteste mais de [ __ ] je vais
l'atteindre en cours pour gars mais
[ __ ] on pro focus tous les bleus on a
gagné les cas c'est grâce à nos
brochette ça tu sais ne descend pas
vipère bien je te jure je te fais rien
non mais tu t'es fait mal tout seul a
été reproché sur mal mondial attend le
mec qui a des coiffes et villageois ces
15 rue jules auber autant mais il peut
pas mourir
non ils peuvent pas eh ben il résiste à
tout âge de voiture bouge pas mais tout
va aller pardon mais tu le fais pas je
saute sur le toit ah ouais faut faire ok
tu vas mourir
[ __ ] les contours de mecha on écoute
on nous sommes de très beaux piqueur
attention est attaquable ou au
j'ai pris d'hachette g + 10 milliards
comment on prend les trucs de feu je
crois qu'il faut marcher dessus et après
et après tu attends en restant au dessus
et là tu es encore vivant
actuellement à peine la capitale est
gravé le cac lâche moi tu vois là on est
caché et ont fait une feinte une feuille
bus cad et c'est vrai enfin jusqu'à je
vais te manger devant le monde aime pas
et ben je n'ai pas mangé m'a coupé les
entrailles en deux ça marche ça modèle
je danse un petit strip teaseuse
c'est bien aïe et tu crois que tu vois
pas mais qui les fesses des villageois
dans les îlots attend on fait une fugue
muscade ont fait de ce brusque mais je
te suis lait sur le feu
attends vient pour une autre classe tu
mets des javelots fait du sport
olympique au canton n'a dit javelot ils
facturent un coéquipier oh oh oh oh t'as
vu ce que je fais me reviendra pas à la
table au centre il a rien vu lui la
carie vers nous au baby baby que jamais
internet où vous donnez témoin et la
montée mot amour à lairière c'est lui tu
vaux pas mais attends mais c'est un
coéquipier mais non c'est un ennemi
merci m'bia mais non c'est un coéquipier
les bleus jaunes mais c'est un ennemi
m'attaquer je te dis un rouge regarde je
te fait saigner voilà tu as un rouge tu
vois bien et du rouge et or de luxe a tu
te tais [ __ ] tu es parti michel bagard
à droite mais ma gars là bas résille
qu'ils ne se défoncent mon gars je vais
me mouiller sa vie au nom du cat hulot
me suis trompé de touché alors demandé
qu'est ce qu'ils attendent un mec qui
nous tirent dessus cela soit possible ou
non c'est notre allié avec avec son art
juste derrière vient d'apprendre voilà
il est archi apprentis ilaria jet son
art qui dépasse de l'arbre la vue est
plus cher vous allez dire à un arbre qui
tire à l'arc le calme il va m'aider
mika revient vite au plat est donc c'est
trop bien car il eût fallu donc mon pote
hymne salut merci crise et chicken ans
dont il va à l'arbalète nec duquel toi
je vais défoncer à l'e3 je prends la
balle est bien mais carrick a vite
découvert au plh le par je te manger mon
amour bien médias bonjour ou des fautes
on l'a tué il a tué vasiliou le deuxième
tube deuxième à jeter replanter au cas
où tu étais pas ses morts mais j'étais
bien mort donc mais merci quand même
mais désolé ça ne la fraude c'est
entièrement de ma faute
non et il attend la neige mais ce que
j'aime assez compliqué
bien dans ses larmes de thaler ses
larmes archi bon il y en avait après moi
je m'étais moquer de lui un mec qui se
fait au tu vas tu rentres tout le rap
ben là je sais mais parce que moi je
protège suivant mes coéquipiers du
couple à pau il le d pet ce qui lui
plaît
ouais je sais rien regardez regardez
mais qui mais qui peuvent stopper on
vient de loin
piquette j'ai eu à à mecha pourquoi tu
fais semblant que c'est pas toi ô taper
sur l'écran et à clermont 7e au dessus
du but
j'étais consentante et avis la violence
je regarde le bixi au liban mais ça fait
voilà c'était attendu chez lui c'est bon
je me le suis fait à mes chalets en bois
à moi au cas où toi t'as vu ça petit
chat elle était trop concentré mais
voilà alors jma savez quelque chose un
jour notre put alors je te sauver tu
fais région à droite
non mais tu me gâche la vue avec ton
pied à droite mais tu gâches ta direct
compliqué j'ai raté donc et ça l'a tué
qu'est ce qu'ils croient bien faire et
c'est du aulas la mecque chômage
oh oui ou au non mais là j'ai vu où il
était du coup et demi à l'arbalète et
demi à l'arbalète a obtenu et demi à
l'arbalète
on s'en fout du maquereau c'est normal
ok et demi à aa
mais non mais non mais non aussi l'aïe
un rouge il fait chier groupe la voilà à
ouais j'ai roulé au gg oh non j'ai raté
elle inquiète paquet
je tiens j'ai tué équipe au jeu têtu m&g
tu as mais les doubles emballage est un
mec qui va arriver de la fumée attention
attention simulation saiper au maire
j'ai raté j'ai raté j'ai besoin de ton
aide au milieu des mecs qui sont en
plein partout mais oui mr riguet emballé
tout le monde quoi dès que j'ai foutu
dire ok bah ouais bah tu écoutes les
autres si le chien bateau maison tout ce
qui touche quoi
non ils sont encore trois qu'on a trop
piquée avec topic
moi tu vois le bleu là bas tu veux
là là là là donc on va attendre les avis
quant à moi je travaille avait mis
gauche molle gauche depuis tour de
vettel
c'est génial je pourrais faire ça toute
la journée quoi aujourd'hui coller du
coup les regards de l'anoci tap le
cadavre garder muscu sans fred n'importe
quoi aux résister tu avais le doigt sur
le bouton de la souris il m'a fait me
gêne c'est pas grave attentat temps je
te protège te protège tir pâtir pas cher
pas cher pas bryan ruiz brian bright
eyes in the smoke est assez dure
longtemps baccouche times voilà un
parfait parfait dans la tête en plus
nickel d'abord vous faire à aider
athènes a alors vers toi tu en sois tu
mourir non je défonce touche panique à
ouais voilà c'est bon on continue et on
dit c'est quoi nos scores 17-9 mort mon
gars pour moi j'ai fait plus de kiel là
une heure que j'ai fait kindle que je
connais sur le toit à droite à bas il
est plus basse et j'arrive aux ailes et
bastien djabou on atteint j'essaie
sparta haut dans le données dans les
nuages
on l'a défoncé bien j'adore regarder
dehors comme ça tu vas te faire du bruit
meurs mais pourquoi tu fais ça tu m'as
fait aussi mais je te pas fait si tu vas
à fait ça
[Musique]
le tir à quoi ça nous mène aux querelles
de cloud pneus là et voilà gens c'est la
fin de cette véritable boucherie je
pense que dans aucune vidéo de
chevalerie on a aussi bien joué ça fait
plaisir de s'en sortir parce qu'à couper
la tête en boucle comme dans toutes les
autres vidéos sur chivalry merci d'avoir
regardé la vidéo on se retrouve très
vite dans une nouvelle touche à tout le
monde
pis
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
elle